okay so there's a video that is going
around on Facebook and on YouTube it's
from an axe TV called systemic racism
explain make some interesting arguments
and I thought it's worthwhile going
through them a little bit so we're gonna
play the video we'll stop it we'll
discuss this video is sponsored by the
bend and brothers brand new course
expert ownership you can learn to own a
business without it owning you stick
around to the end of the video to find
out more details this is Jamal Jamal is
a boy who lives in a poor neighborhood
he has a friend named Kevin who lives in
a wealthy neighborhood all of Jamal's
neighbors are african-american and all
of Kevin's neighbors are white because
Jamal school district is mostly funded
by property taxes his school is not very
well funded his classrooms are
overcrowded his teachers are underpaid
and he doesn't have access to high
quality tutors or extracurricular
activities
Kevin School District is also funded by
property taxes so high school is very
well funded his classrooms are never
crowded his teachers are very well-paid
and he has access to high quality tutors
and lots of extracurricular activities
so let's talk for a second about school
policy the reality is that if you wanted
Jamal to be able to go to Kevin's school
what you'd want is something called
school vouchers you want people to be
able to move away from their school
districts one of the chief reasons that
Jamal is confined to his local public
school is because of Democratic policy
that has decided that you must go to
school in the district where you live
and this is also why a lot of people
have left lower-income areas and moved
out to higher income areas specifically
for better public school so if you want
Jamal to have the same educational
opportunities as Kevin perhaps you
should have school vouchers for private
schools or perhaps you should have
charter schools which is what Mayor Bill
DeBlasio in New York is fighting against
or perhaps you should break the teachers
unions which are costing a fortune
particularly on a disproportionate level
in areas where they're not spending
enough taxpayer dollars so I'm all for
improving Jamal's schools I'm also
offered from all having all the same
educational opportunities as Kevin the
problem is most Democrats are not Kevin
and Jamal live only a few streets away
from each other so how come they're
growing up in such different worlds with
such different opportunities for success
the answer has to do with America's
history of systemic racism to understand
it better let's look at what life was
like for Kevin and Jamal's grandparents
in order to understand what's gonna
happen in this video you have to
understand how systemic racism is being
defined systemic racism is really a
morphus term it could mean many things
it could mean that the institution
today are racist in which case everyone
would oppose them or it could mean that
all inequality is explainable by racism
which of course is not sustainable it's
not a good argument the argument that
this video is going to try to make is
that all of history has meaning and that
is true history does have consequences
before today the problem is is we'll see
the video tries to explain all
inequality with reliance on history and
no inequality with response to
exacerbating levels of income inequality
exacerbating levels of single motherhood
personal decision making or any of the
other variables that could come into
creating the gaps we see today decades
after the Civil War many government
agencies started to draw maps dividing
cities into sections that were either
desirable or undesirable for investment
this practice was called redlining and
it usually blocked off an entire black
neighborhoods from access to private and
public investment banks and insurance
companies use these maps for decades to
deny black people loans and other
services based purely on race
historically speaking owning a home and
getting a college education is the
easiest way for an American family to
build wealth but when jamel's
grandparents wanted to buy a house the
banks refused because they lived in a
neighborhood that was redlining
so Jamal's grandparents were not able to
buy a home and because colleges could
prevent them from attending through
legal segregation their options for
higher education were really scarce so
let's talk about redlining redlining
became illegal in the United States as
early as 1968 the Equal Credit
Opportunity Act was followed by the Home
Mortgage Disclosure Act in 1975 which
was a predecessor to the Community
Reinvestment Act both of which were an
attempt to ensure that people who are
living in low-income minority
neighborhoods could actually get loans
and these things were very effective in
1992 researchers at the Federal Reserve
Bank of Boston tried to look at the data
they collected information on some 30
variables related to lending decisions
they found that virtually all of the
difference between minority and
non-minority denial rates was explained
by those variables a reanalysis of that
information found that black owned banks
were actually lending to white owned
businesses at higher rates than they
were lending to black owned businesses
furthermore if it seemed the banks were
discriminating against black borrowers
on the basis of they needed to have
higher credit qualifications what you
would see is lower default rates from
black
of banks from people who are borrowing
money from banks and black community
there are zero studies that show any of
this so the bottom line is this
redlining was in evil and awful policy
it was maybe legal in the 1960s by the
1980s it the banks were not lending at
disproportionate rates in fact if you
look at among different communities as
Thomas all has pointed out
asian-americans get loans more easily
than white Americans that does not mean
the banks are being racist toward white
Americans on behalf of Asian Americans
when it comes to college education it is
also worth noting that yes there are
many universities that were segregated
there are many universities that did not
allow black people to attend since the
1970s the most prominent measure that
has been used in order to admit black
students to major universities across
the country has been affirmative action
which actively discriminates against
people who are not black in favor of
black applicants specifically by
ensuring that black applicants don't
have to have the same test scores or
GPAs in order to get into those same
schools so not only has policy been
corrected it's been over corrected in
these areas Kevin's grandparents on the
other hand at a low interest loan to buy
their first house and get accepted into
a handful of top universities which
traditionally only accepted white
students this opened up a wealth of
opportunities that they were able to
pass on to their kids and grandkids
the basic assumption of this video is
that if your grandparents are rich in
the United States this means that you
are rich in the United States the
different grandparents are poor in the
United States that means the you are
poor in the United States this is
factually untrue the reality is that
income changes over time that there are
an enormous number of people in the
United States by percentage who are able
to rise from portes middle class and
their children from middle class to
wealthy the biggest problem that we have
in the United States right now is not a
historic wealth gap the biggest problem
we have is an income gap in the United
States and there's some fascinating
statistics surrounding this there's a
Harvard study recently that showed that
black males who are growing up in the
same household incomes as white males
were actually underperforming their
white male counterparts even in high
income neighborhoods you would think
that all of this might imply racism
except for one inconvenient fact in the
study black women who are growing up in
the same high income neighborhoods as
white women growing up in the same high
income neighborhoods black women were
performing at exactly the same or higher
rates than white women in those
neighborhoods which would suggest that
there are other factors at play other
than simple racism furthermore the basic
idea that most wealth in the United
States is inherited and the
millionaire's are really only
millionaires
because their parents were millionaires
that really isn't true either the vast
majority of millionaires and
billionaires are people whose parents
were not millionaires and billionaires
chris hogan who's a black financial
expert he did a survey of 10,000 people
and what he found was that of those
10,000 people 74% of millennials
believed millionaires inherited their
money 52% of baby boomers did but only
21% of millionaires received any
inheritance at all just 16% inherited
more than $100,000 only 3% receives an
inheritance at or above 1 million
dollars in reality the best path toward
wealth in this country is income
mobility not inherited wealth this
opened up a wealth of opportunities that
they were able to pass on to their kids
and grandkids even as late as the 1980s
an investigation into the Atlanta
real-estate market showed that banks
were more willing to lend to low-income
white families than to middle or upper
income African American families as a
result today for every hundred dollars
of wealth held by a white family
Kwak families have five dollars and four
cents it 2017 study confirms that
redlining is still affecting home values
and major cities like Chicago today this
explains how Kevin and Jamaal inherited
vastly different circumstances as it
turns out there are some complicating
factors that don't get cited in this
video through guard to the state of the
Federal Reserve Board economists tried
to explain that this data did not take
account of differences that were not
income based things like liabilities
employment history credit record and
other relevant variables that should
have been considered it should not be
particularly surprising that
discrimination in the past has impact on
the actual income of people who are
living in the areas that were denied
loans that shouldn't be a major surprise
but that is not the only disparity
obviously that New York Times piece they
are citing says quote they estimate the
map's account for 15 to 30 percent of
the overall gaps in segregation and
homeownership that they find between the
highest risk area and the second highest
risk areas those were the ones that are
being classified the truth is that when
it comes to redlining you have to look
at the gradations as well there was
always going to be a difference in the
availability of loans to people who are
living in the highest risk areas as
opposed to the people who are in the
very lowest risk areas another factor is
that if history does make a difference
then if you are denied loans in a
particular area and if there's less
money in those areas and as crime goes
up and as property taxes
there's not enough money to take it as
schools get worse obviously that's going
to continue to have effect in that
particular area that doesn't mean the
same people are living in that area who
always lived in that area or the people
who grew up in that area in 1960
necessarily have to live in that area or
that their grandkids have to live in
that area in 2020 unfortunately the
story doesn't end there a big part of
systemic racism is implicit bias these
are prejudices in society that people
are not aware that they have one of the
big problems with implicit bias it is
very very difficult to quantify identify
and studies that supposedly determine
that your implicit bias results in real
world action are deeply flawed implicit
bias assessment tests for example are so
significantly flawed they're virtually
unusable let's go back to Kevin and
Jamal against all odds' Jamal manages to
be the only student from his high school
to get accepted into a great university
the same one that Kevin and his high
school friends are attending but after
Kevin and Jamal both graduate
Jamal notices that his resume isn't
drawn as much interest as Kevin's even
though they graduated from the same
program with the exact same GPA
unfortunately for Jamal studies show
that resumes with white sounding names
get twice as many callbacks as identical
resumes with black sounding names the
research is actually a lot more
interesting than what is being portrayed
in this video there are several studies
here there is one famous study that was
done that suggested that first name
differentiation was indeed being used by
employer so if your name was Laquisha
for example this is the name that is
actually used in the study Lakeisha
versus Greg that you are less likely to
get a call back there was another study
that showed a historically black last
name like Washington or Jefferson
provided no actual differentiation from
historically white names a Greenberg for
example so if your name was Steve
Greenberg versus Steve Jefferson you're
just as likely to get a call back as
Steve Jefferson what that suggests and
this was confirmed by subsequent studies
is that the actual issue here is a
question of class discrimination not an
issue of race discrimination in other
words the reason that people are
discriminating against Lakeisha as
opposed to against Steve Johnson or
Steve Washington is because people are
actually using the first name as it
stands in for social class they are
figuring that if you were named Lakeisha
it's because you probably came from a
more impoverished background now this is
not
restricted to the black community this
happens in the Jewish community as well
if you get an applicant and the
applicants name is Ben you might treat
that applicant different than if that
person's name is Benny I mean you might
treat a Menachem different than you
treat a mic and that is because you are
trying to read into the person your
perceptions of culture or perceptions of
class not really perceptions of race
that's really really important when you
look at these particular studies and
suggests that racial discrimination
rather than class distinctions are at
the basis of whatever hiring
discrimination is happening here
implicit bias is one of the reasons why
the black unemployment rate is twice the
rate of white unemployment well this
tends to neglect one key factor what did
you major in what did you study it turns
out that people who major in education
aren't gonna do as well as people who
major in engineering according to
research from the Center on education
and the workforce at Georgetown
University there's a quote from PBS
african-american college students are
more likely to pursue majors that lead
to low-paying jobs
setting up many for future debt and
underemployment over time these
occupational choices contribute to the
wealth and opportunity gap between
whites and blacks that spans generations
anthony karneval who's the director of
the program says basically
african-americans have been going to the
right church but sitting in the wrong
pew in a way they are using education to
climb the social and economic ladder but
they're being steered toward majors that
will make them lower earners so in other
words there are several confounding
factors that are not being taken into
account in this video one what college
did you go to - what did you major in
and three what kind of job did you get
afterward you can see evidence of
systemic racism in every area of life
the disparities and family wealth
incarceration rates political
representation and education are all
examples of systemic racism now we reach
the crux of the matter the basic idea
here is that any inequality can be
chalked up to systemic racism we are now
ghost-hunting
notice they've said nothing in this
video about incarceration nothing about
incarceration the simple assumption is
that if more black people
percentage-wise are arrested than white
people that must be due to systemic
racism and not due to the number of
crimes being committed by individuals
who make a decision to commit a crime
when it comes to representation the
truth is there are many many black
Americans in Congress we've had a black
presidents of the United States people
choosing to run in people choosing to
vote that is an aspect of American
freedom and when it comes to education
there are plenty of affirmative action
programs that exist at virtually every
major university in fact their entire
university systems like the University
of California
have gotten rid of the SAT in the a CT
as admissions criteria specifically
because they weren't allowing enough
minority students to attend so to
attribute all inequality to systemic
racism is simply to say that everything
you don't like must be due to systemic
racism unfortunately the biggest
challenge is systemic racism is that
there's no single person or entity
responsible for it which makes it very
hard to solve so what can you do
the first thing you can do is work
towards becoming more aware of your own
implicit biases we should always as
decent people be re-examining our own
biases in trying to wipe out bad
thoughts who may be having about other
people but the idea that something is
vague as you had a bad thought about a
group is now responsible for the income
inequality between black and white is
sort of an absurd contention in the
absence of any available evidence what
are some prejudice is that you might
hold that you're not aware of second
let's acknowledge that the consequences
of slavery and Jim Crow laws are still
affecting access to opportunity today it
is certainly plausible that slavery and
Jim Crow have affected how people's
paths have gone in life and the
circumstances of their birth but the
question is how much if we are going to
change policy and if we were going to
effectuate change
shouldn't we be focused more on what are
the bad policies today that specifically
are keeping people down and what
behaviors can we change today to make
our opportunities better rather than
focusing in on slavery or Jim Crow the
fact is that even if you buy into the
entire narrative of systemic racism
promoted by this video it changes
nothing and the video is even
acknowledging as much as a result we
should support systemic changes that
create more equal opportunities for
everyone
increasing public school funding and
making it independent from property
taxes would be a great start so that
poor and wealthy districts can receive
equal access to resources the suggestion
that simply pouring money into public
schools is somehow going to be the
solution has been bolide by nearly every
independent study ever done of public
education obviously we should be
spending more on City on schools where
not enough spending is going on where
there aren't school books or there
aren't enough desks but the real problem
that's existing in educational
performance has very little to do with
income and a lot more to do with the
access to educational opportunity
provided in in homes if you have a
single family home it is very difficult
for mom to be able to help with homework
if you don't allow kids to go to better
schools outside their neighborhood
rather than simply pouring money in
two failed neighborhood schools then
you're not really granting opportunity
systemic problems require systemic
solutions luckily we're all part of the
system which means that we all have a
role to play in making it better peace
it's easy enough to say that we all have
a role in making the system better but
when you suggest very few practical
solutions other than rote democratic
policies that have been failed nearly
every time they've tried it makes it
difficult to believe this isn't just a
political ploy rather than an argument
in favor of bettering individual human
lives to deny the effects of history
would be idiotic history obviously has
consequences and to deny that racism
exists would be similarly idiotic but to
attribute every problem in American life
to racism or inequity is to be foolish
and counterproductive and not to make
the world a better place for more on a
lot of these topics go check out my
brand new book how to destroy America in
three easy steps all about the attempt
to divide Americans by suggesting that
American philosophy culture and history
are responsible for all wrongs in the
modern world go check out that book it's
available everywhere also if you enjoyed
this video please give it a like we
really appreciate it and check out my
show the venture Pierrot show now there
are a lot of folks who reach the
pinnacle of business life and they are
just as miserable as they ever were it
doesn't have to be that way you should
be able to own your business without it
owning you and this is why I want to
tell you about my friends the Benham
brothers I know them they are good
Christian men they have over a dozen
businesses including a real estate
portfolio in over 35 states and they
didn't sell their soul to get it you
might remember their names they were
supposed to have a reality TV show on
HGTV and they were basically thrown out
of reality TV for the great sin of being
Christian because of their commitment to
conservative values so-called business
coaches will tell you that your life has
to take a backseat to your business but
David and Jason Benham they know that
that is not true they are proof that
that is a lie just recently the Benham
brothers launched a new course is called
expert ownership it's the model they use
to build all of their businesses whether
you're sick of the nine survive whether
you're just eager to get a new business
started or whether you've had a business
for ten years expert ownership can help
you achieve your goals to celebrate the
launch of that brand new course they're
offering 15% off to new members you can
check out a preview of the course and
take advantage of that discount over at
Benham brothers dot-com
/ Ben that's B and H am brothers dot-com
/ men for 15% off you can also find a
link in the description of this video
head on over there and check out their
brand-new course
expert ownership